it certainly looked like a drawdown but
is it or are these images willingly
released by the russians or part of the
game brinkmanship for vladimir putin on
the border
in washington it prompted a statement
from president biden and a reality check
as the americans see it our analysts
indicate that they remain very much in a
threatening position
and the fact remains right now russia
has more than 150 000 troops encircling
ukraine and belarus and along ukraine's
border
an invasion remains distinctly possible
the president's life address was hastily
announced but delivered with a striking
directness
to the citizens of russia
you are not our enemy
and i do not believe you want a bloody
destructive war against ukraine
a country and a people with whom you
share such deep ties of family history
and culture
he was careful to span out that he
didn't seek to provoke
with so much at stake he and his speech
writers needed this to be word perfect
world war ii
was a war of necessity
but if russia attacks ukraine it would
be a war of choice
or a war without cause or reason the
change in tone on the prospect of an
invasion was subtle no longer imminent a
distinct possibility instead but the
messaging was powerful with that
decision to address the russian people
directly
in moscow the german chancellor met
president putin who was no doubt
enjoying the attention of the latest
european leader to sit at the end of his
long table but the russian president's
red lines seem immovable
and listen for the false claim of
genocide which could be his excuse to
move in as well
[Music]
the russians are ready 150 000 soldiers
half the air force an extraordinary
military movement some in washington had
suggested today would be putin's
invasion day but behind that jeopardy
they now say diplomacy could yet prevail
mark stone sky news in washington